Stephen wrote in saying David are you
willing to watch strangers belongings at
a library or coffee shop this is
actually a really funny question because
I had an experience with Genki ogre from
The Young Turks that relates directly to
this when I was living in New York City
I met Genk at a I don't remember what
coffee shop it was it honestly it might
have been that bad one that I no longer
go to anymore but in any case I met jenk
at a coffee shop and we were sitting
there just chatting about stuff and a
guy maybe 60 year old guy comes over and
says he's got a big bag and he says
excuse me guys I need to go to the
bathroom is it okay if I leave this bag
here and you'll watch it and my instinct
in these situations is normally to say
sure right but jenk
did not have any of it jenk actually
said listen I'm sorry I don't know you I
don't know what's in the bag
and I don't know how long you're gonna
be gone for I'm just not comfortable
watching the bag and at this point I
perk up and I'm like this well this is
getting interesting very quickly and the
guy sort of became argumentative and
said oh I'm just gonna be a few minutes
and jenk I think said something like
well why not just take the bag with you
like you don't just take the bag to the
bathroom this isn't a target where
you're not allowed to enter the bathroom
with any unpaid-for merchandise it's
just a personal bag that you've got and
the guy I don't remember if the guy
brought the bag with him into the
bathroom or found someone else but it
was a fascinating moment because I've up
until that point other than maybe on
Curb Your Enthusiasm I've never seen in
the real world someone refused to watch
someone's bag and Jenk did it and I
loved it yeah and I understand why you
would refuse I guess I just don't think
I would start that argument you know
it's something you don't have to really
be confrontational about it's basically
if there are just gonna last a few
minutes in there so you would basically
just agree to watch it but then leave if
you want to leave I would I would agree
to watch it yeah but I wouldn't be the
person to request that someone else
watches my belongings because what
reason do I have to trust them over
anyone else I mean your fear is that a
stranger will come and take it yeah
they're just as much of a stranger as
anyone else right you want you want a
stranger to protect your stuff from
other strangers no but I actually don't
agree with that I do think that there is
a little bit of a difference because as
soon as you make a connection with that
stranger they're no longer as much of a
stranger as someone that might run in
from the street and take your laptop
yeah and the idea is maybe you've been
both working on your own for about an
hour yeah you've been observing ones
reading a book or something yeah and in
fact yesterday I was about I was at a
coffee shop doing work yesterday and I
was going to get up to go to the
bathroom and I I was about to say to the
guy next to me hey could you just watch
my laptop I'll be right back
he asked me two seconds before and I
said sure and the difference between a
sketchy-looking bag and this guy was all
I was being asked to watch was his
laptop on the count on his table there
was no bag with a bunch of hidden stuff
where who knows what's in it it was just
his laptop I know what I'm watching and
I'm comfortable with that I've actually
seen these prank videos where someone
will leave of a backpack or a dog with a
stranger to watch for them and then a
completely different person will come
along and grab it from them all part of
the Frank and it's just this interesting
social experiment because some people
will just not really understand what
went on or not even focused on the fact
that there's a new person here taking
the belongings right it's really
interesting to see most people just let
it slide I wonder how many people don't
notice that the person who comes back to
grab the dog is not the same person who
asked you to watch them right right as
possible somebody would even notice so
anyway generally speaking I will watch
people stuff but I do also sympathize
with Genki ogres view Hey I don't know
you and I don't know what's in the bag
and I don't know when you're coming back
but ultimately and maybe this is just a
horrible thing for me to say if the
person was gone for half an hour I'd
probably just leave and I wouldn't feel
guilty because if they are asking me to
watch something for a minute or two it
is at some point their responsibility
not to leave me with the stuff for a
half hour right like I can't really just
be my fault that this person never came
back too great of a responsibility to
put on you in the first place I mean
you're overplaying your hand I get I
agree I it's incredibly audacious to
just disappear for a half-hour so anyway
yeah I I will watch I am willing to
watch but I will leave if the person
takes too long so that that's that we've
got a great bonus show planned for you
today david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show two
great ways to support the show and get
access to the bonus show